this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
thanks a lot Andy it's a pleasure to be
here for many reasons because Andy is a
very very good friend and I missed him
when he left
submit for Cornell I was a bit upset
about Cornell of course but I think it's
also because I know Cornell for a long
time and that's my first visit ever so I
think I know content by reputation by
its good reputation by the publication's
and by many colleagues who graduated
from from Cornell and we've worked in
the CG or still working in the CG system
so many things to be so numerous here
today and when I gave a similar image
here if usually small room so it's it's
great I will try to give you an overview
of the work we do in submit through the
lens of mechanization and its
representation I made for the board we
our board of trustees
you know I want to know a bit more about
our programs and they usually want to
have something on mechanization I say
not again mechanization so this
presentation is not a bad mechanization
it's the lens of mechanization and
system and intensification through the
lens of mechanization before I start I
have a couple of slides about the CGI
our research centres and I how many of
you heard about the CG I don't need to
explain it very long so the city was
created at the end of the 60s beginning
of the 70s as a body of centers I think
initially they were just few centers
submit is one of the oldest one and we
just celebrated our 50 and over Surrey
and not so long ago two years ago
where's the mandate to look at research
for development or research in
development so the the the CG was
created with now we have about 15
centers a lot of changes that fill up
and in the next two years and I don't
want to go into that because it's made a
big interrelation mark our the CG will
will be shaped in two years time but it
was created just to cover most of the
developing countries but in term of
geographies and also in term of domotics
so Simmons is the center working on
maize and wheat so it's known as
International maize and wheat
Improvement Center we do much more than
reading because we are still very well
known by a by a breeding component but
we do much more than than reading and we
are also I word about the CRP CGI
research programs
much less it's not as popular that was
the last reform of the CG that was about
eight years eight nine years ago so
research research programs were created
and they are about 15 research programs
we are leading to research programs one
on maize one on wheat
we are also leading a platform which is
something a bit different than a problem
and newer the excellence in reading and
we are part of the agriculture for
nutrition and health led by if free and
also by the the seek after time exchange
ERP which is led by ICF we are also
contributing to the Big Data Platform
the gene bank platform and to the PIM
the policy institutions and markets so
it's those efforts I made for us to work
better together as as a body of of
centuries let's go back to cistern
abandon intensification through the lens
of of mechanization and I thought that
my presentation to the board would be
boring and I really got excited the more
I thought about that and the more I
developed my slides I thought well
that's a really nice exercise just
take something as you know narrowest
mechanization and just look at its
impact in the system so the key messages
we are probably d by father the center
having the largest portfolio on
mechanization if free has worked a bit
on mechanization but mostly on the on
the policy issue we work in Asia Africa
and Latin America that's you know we
submit as offices in several countries
and we are covering our regions as Latin
America but mainly in Mexico but also
subscribe Africa mostly Eastern and
Southern Africa
and then South Asia where we have the
largest portfolio in our program and
that's thanks to Andy will develop that
portfolio in a very efficient manner so
we have a long history especially in
South Asia and I think Peter Hobbs is
maybe here Peter are you there yeah
Peter is there and I think it's one of
the pioneer it was involved in
conservation agriculture and in
mechanization word because I mean those
two are very much linked that's one of
the the challenge on conservation
agriculture is linked to to
mechanization and there was previous to
the CRPS there was feral eco regional
programs and the rice with consortium
was one and I think was very efficient I
mean I joined seam it after that that
program that consortium was was closed
but I think it was very very efficient
and that was the one that was the
foundation for working in it in South
Asia and we work with if with if free
and Olivia and either the the rice
research institution so our work on
making mechanization is broader than
engineering so it's systemic approach to
mechanization in fact we don't have many
engineers
potential contribution of mechanization
to sustainable intensification in small
girl farming systems the contribution of
mechanization to social inclusion is
also very promising and I show few
slides about about that the effective
ways to scale mechanization is to
public/private partnership commerce
commercialization creation of business
opportunity for service provision and I
have few slides about that as well but
we just don't want to be in church we
went with research at the end with an
impact on the ground on the largest
number of smaller the farmers possible
so there's a strong policy dimension and
I will just show you also a few slides
linked to the policy dimension so where
do we work on mechanization we have a
large flagship program in Mexico called
Mossad room and we have a strong
mechanization component there we work
with ekkada which is another city center
in northern northern Africa on rain-fed
weeds systems and the week the we t.o.p
initiative we work in East and Southern
Africa and we have different funding
there with a good funding from the
Australian ACR which is the focusing
project we are funded by the Germans as
well if some interested mechanization
does gi8
and we are linking with if you on a
project in Zambia funded by the European
Union so the largest in our program the
largest portfolio is in South Asia is
about 50% of our funding and there we
work under the sisa portfolio it's a
series of projects all connected under
the we see RP and also under the Borlaug
Institute for South Asia which is a
structure that was created by Civic to
work in India and again a Australian
funding on this surface here projects so
we have a diversity of geographies where
we work very different biophysical but
also social socio economic environments
CG Center
supposed to work at both the national
level or the local level that's the
richness of what we do and that's
probably what we can bring to a national
programs because we work a lot with
national research programs and
development structuring countries so you
can imagine that's tree landscapes the
first one is a very very large field the
second one is a very fragmented
landscape in in Bangladesh and the other
one is a landscape in in Kenya so the
second one is mostly rice based systems
the one in Kenya is made mostly maize
based systems so you can imagine that
with such a diversity in field size
mechanization solution might be quite
different opportunities and constraints
to adoption of mechanization can be
quite different so
trying to find scale appropriate tools
to work on the different landscape is
one of the the objective of our research
there was large efforts in pushing
mechanization in the seventies eighties
in Africa and it was a major failure I
remember when I worked in each year in
early 90s I think the average lifespan
of a tractor was below and red hours and
that was just state schemes that was
funded mostly by the World Bank I
believe and it was a complete failure so
for a moment I mean the thing is that in
the work we do sometimes people judge it
doesn't work they don't and they don't
look at why it didn't work it doesn't
work so we don't look at it anymore so
we had about in Africa about eight nine
years ago we wanted just to look at
opportunities for mechanization because
we could see that the adoption of
mechanization in South Asia for small
oldest farming systems was something
very interesting
so large-scale mechanization and
conservation agriculture one good thing
about conservation agriculture is that
you don't need to have primary tillage
that means that you can work with less
horsepower than smaller tractors that's
the big big advantage we're also looking
at mechanization with the minimum
negative social and environmental
consequences so in terms of the need for
land consolidation if you have large
mechanization schemes or the labor
displacement and the solar rotation
which is a major focus of our research
as well and our focus on conservation
agriculture in our program
so machines should adapt adapt to farm
size and it seems quite sometimes she
still schemes in Africa where people are
coming with large tractor I went to John
Deere few years ago and close to Chicago
and to date course and they didn't like
what I was presenting because their
business is to sell the largest tractor
possible they don't like conservation
agriculture very much so in the context
of sustainable intensification we look
at the impact of mechanization on
different things the most obvious one is
as labor is the major limiting factor to
productivity of all the systems and at
times in in cropping systems for farming
systems where labor is really missing
and have a negative impact on on yields
so you can see two of the publication
from from from our group related to that
and I can give you know the list of
publication I've cited it and the
presentation will be in this related as
well as nothing secret there so
proper
Dishman is the most critical time of the
year and that's valid also in South Asia
and irrigated system so it's not only
water but what you can see there is a
seven-day difference with maize on the
left side maize on the right side seven
days delay can have a dramatic effect on
yield so you can see that cloud of of of
points and that's for South Asia so a
delay in sowing days and impact on wheat
yield envy are the reason there is not
like in rain fed system it's more like
terminal each stress you can have on on
wheat if you plan too late the width in
the indo-gangetic Plains there are two
seasons the cold season and a moon soon
the wheat is grown during the Cold
season but at the end of the the wheat
cycle temperatures increase so the earth
terminal is stressed and having an a
large impact from a [ __ ] so crop
established
also very demanding and that's and see
the work that's done here in Ethiopia
with a pair of oxen and that's classical
tillage and you can see the amount of of
soul movement done by those ladies in in
East Africa so one thing that's
important in mechanization planting
seeding and one of the challenge with
the equipment for under conservation
agriculture and and-and-and lauch is to
go through the mulch so that's one of
the the work we do is trying to find the
best or develop the best planters that
can go through the amount of crop
residue left on the field and we have
solutions we have four-wheel tractor
solutions we have two we'll practice
solutions depending on the and the area
where we where we work so that's the
work
mechanization some of the labour
measures done in in East Africa you can
see that the conventional establishment
it's requiring quite a lot of hours and
the mechanized she is just much much
reduced so it's a major impact on on
labour and that means that you don't
have to work two or three weeks to
establish all your fields you can work
much faster and then you have an impact
on yield as well so that's all the
different operations and the classical
time what's taking the the most time is
the Easter planting so you have the
manual and you have mechanised
mechanization
and war
water is also an important input in most
on all the farming systems where we work
major impact has been done on working on
laser land leveling in in India over the
last 20 years I think Peter when when
they did start the land it is a so of
course Asim it we didn't create the
technology laser land levelling was
existing and was using and us quite
intensively in places like like Utah but
we worked with national partners and we
developed you know schemes for rail and
leveling having a major impact on on
water management in in those systems so
I think right now in India thing was bad
six million a tropism they've been laser
land level and of course time to time
you need to do to be level your your
field so there's a good business around
around that we are working more on
technology of tomorrow I mean we're just
developing some doing some research on
subsurface drip irrigation and we get
fantastic weather use efficiency systems
plus the option of control much better
fertilizer inputs true fertigation so we
have some some some work there the the
slide on the bottom left is about actual
flow pumps that can be paired with the
pto of of a two wheel tractor so that
means that if you don't have too much of
course that struction those you can your
lift cannot be done that that large but
in bangladesh you can usually find you
know open water and bring it to your
fields so that's also a very interesting
option for for farmers for supplemental
irrigation and we have mechanized also
and as a prototype has been developed at
the visa station to lay down drip lines
under the surface the good thing was
minimum tillage so reduce tillage or no
tillage is that you can put your lines
down and you don't need to remove them
at the end of the season so it's
if you don't have too much rodents
around you can probably keep your lines
through years
so impact at scale that's the the
figures I was talking about on laser
leveling so yes now four thousand forty
thousand units in India and was mainly
done through private investment and
service provision so that's that can be
you know a good model for developing and
scaling mechanization in other parts of
the world as well so you can see all the
figures just impact on on you know water
management water savings on yields on
employment on electricity savings one of
the issue yes that water is subsidized I
mean pumping is not cost electricity
subsidized for pumping so it's a bit of
a problem when you want to incent and
certify things that are free I just
usually abused so there are some some
also some research and linking that to a
policy the policy component
mechanization and nutrient use plan
nutrition plan nutrient juice so
mechanization is obviously improving to
directly to of the for our principles
the right rate I mean if you if you have
fertilizer application with with your
planter or your direct print cedar and
the right place as well so place and
rate and you increase profitability and
you reduce also winners gas emissions
and nitrate teaching which is a major
problem in many systems were working
with social include
that's those are data from from our
project in in Africa Eastern southern
Africa and that shows over the year the
access to mechanization and we are just
monitoring I mean it's very important
now our donors are not interested in
publications most of the time they're
interested in actually you can generate
either directly or indirectly so that's
part of the monitoring we have done
mechanization in in in Africa
sub-saharan Africa is still a big big
challenge for many reasons but we want
to continue to work on that so on the
the equity issue was access to
mechanization it's also a very important
question and and you look at the
investment costs for a large structure
and you look at the investment costs for
you know the animal attraction and
two-wheel tractors the problem was with
animal attraction is that you usually
use your animals for one two three weeks
during the year and the rest of the year
you have to feed those animals with prop
residues and feet so one of the issue of
conservation agriculture adoption in
Africa is also the trade-off between
preferences you use so going to a
mechanized option a fully mechanized
option and not going through animal
traction is probably much more promising
although I mean animal traction might
look very romantic but it's not the best
use of resources in small other farming
systems so again
cost when you go from conventional
practices with four-wheel tractors to
two-wheel tractors conservation
agriculture the cost is much much lower
and you have again in the middle of the
cost of animal traction when you have to
you know take care of your of your
animals during between between two two
seasons youth I mean it was a big topic
in in in the CG few years ago how can we
make agriculture attractive for young
people in developing countries I think
we have all the same the same problem I
think agriculture is not very sexy in
Europe it's not very sexy in the US but
we had a lot of consolidation in
developing countries in many places
that's the only livelihood option for
four people and you have a lot of
migrations to cities and so on so
population is often aging very very
quickly in in small systems in Asia and
in Africa so that's an example where you
had you know mesh error which in one
season generated 6700 borers which from
our standard might not look very big but
it's very very big enough in large
amount of money so we are looking also
and you know on those service provision
and how much how long it takes to return
year to 12 the return on investment and
usually it's quite quite short gender
impact that's a very very simple Scherer
again but this was you
reduction in labor demand and bursaries
for that it went from 12 days per ton to
one hour so it's this is Africa this is
the work in in in Bangladesh and again
we are monitoring and we are looking at
the impact of mechanization on on
different important lively components
child care activities cooking our farm
laborer livestock poultry income
generation so the time you free on your
operations - mechanization you can
invest it in income generating
activities Arvest incurring threshing
have to manage form labourers time spent
spend on later in leisure
I mean life in small farms in developing
countries can be tough this is something
that's very I think profitable for
people as well a mess linked to the drug
Treasury and and it's there is a strong
gender dimension to that as well usually
women were much more many more hours in
rural landscapes in Africa in Asia than
men time sleeping as well I mean
sleeping it's important so it's an
interesting study showing the you know
just the implication of of one
mechanization option which is the Reaper
of Esther so how do we scale that I mean
it's the question is that in Asia is
already a large adoption of
mechanization options in Africa it's
just at the beginning so we are looking
at model to scale out appropriate
organization and one key thing is
service provision commercialization so
professionalization of the activity I
don't we don't dream about every farmer
having a small two-wheel tractors I
think the service provision is much more
efficient so
that's the classical adoption technology
adoption curve and I would say that in
Africa we are about there I think in
some places in in in Asia we are still
we are there and the research questions
are still very interesting even with
adoption at scale that's very
interesting aspect so being able to work
under that adoption technology adoption
continuum is also very interesting for
us and learning also from what we do in
Asia for the future in Africa that's one
of the project we have in in Bangladesh
and that shows the growth since the
beginning of the project on machinery
service provision so again that's part
of the monitoring and evaluation that's
the USAID that's the US funded project
USAID and very important that we
document also so those are the
achievement after the phase one of the
project and we are now going into a
phase two which is a bit different and
it's been redesigned but those are not
small numbers large numbers and I mean
we are pretty proud of that so we are
not a pure research institution we have
at the end working for impacts on on the
ground so a lot of work has been done in
Bangladesh and in other places as well
to look at at the best business models
for scaling mechanization increasing
adoption of mechanization options and we
even a scaling specialist now in Simmons
we call it like that looking among other
things at mechanization options in
different systems so that's a slide
where you see a my favorite US president
from the left side and that guy is jail
Oliver is a kind of innovator and here's
Ronald rats so you know went very well
and we are trying to work with him so
it's you know digital agriculture
there's also options on service
provision cell phones and so on so it's
very exciting type of work it calls it
uber for tractors and that's also a
great tool to monitor you know the work
of equipments in the field and so on
Indians if they own system which is very
similar and there are some manufacturers
now that you know working on the the
scaling of monitoring systems and and
service provision and comment systems
for for for FAO is a big player does the
new new director general of FAO we
visited us before being elected
it was campaigning in Mexico so we have
discussing China is an interesting
country because the progress this
probably the country with the largest
number of manufacturers of two-wheel
tractors more implements and so on so
it's a great place to go and shop so the
business models we are looking we're of
course looking at service provision but
it's not good enough I mean you need to
create the market you need to create
import schemes you need to train people
in local workshops to you know develop
and/or repair the equipment so it's a an
FAO is well implemented in that in that
regard so working with a few in
mechanization makes a lot of sense
information knowledge communication is
also very important my thing we have
done quite interesting videos especially
in in South Asia I guess how many videos
do we have and the ability
quite a few no yeah so and we have her
briefs and we have a lot of things
capacity development and we have we are
running conservation agriculture
training courses at least once a year in
in Mexico and once a year in in South
Asia so it's also very important to to
enhance you know capabilities in
different countries were working work so
I was I was teased by by by the top
management of Simeon they say you work
you do interesting work in mechanization
and it's not visible and sometimes
people don't don't see what they don't
want to see but so we have we've done a
specific efforts in in trying to to
brand our work for different reasons I
mean for people being interested by the
topic from all the research or
development organizations for
fundraising I mean we work only on soft
soft funding so we have to raise money
for for the work we want to do but
there's been a lot of tweets and
discussion when we are using Twitter we
are using Facebook using different
different one interesting aspects
related to mechanization is and you
probably heard about the air pollution
problem in Northwest India in Delhi
which is not only due to crop residue
burning but crop residue burning is
adding a layer of pollution at the time
of Christ's harvesting which is in
November and rice residues are burned
not because farmers like to burn things
it's because they have to prepare the
land for the for the the wheats
subsequent weeks wheat crop so the time
the time is not that big and that's the
first one of the first light I show that
the penalty begin penalty you have on
wheat by delaying your wheat planting so
the easiest way to get rid of crop
you is just to burn it so we've been
looking for a long time I think Peter
the first version of the a PC there was
developed one it was Australian funding
yeah initially black black well yeah and
that was in so the thing is also that's
the message you know long-term
investment pay I mean some donors like
after getting very impatient right the
project in three years you have to wait
for four years you have to have impact
that scale doesn't work like that
I think sustained investment and
coherence in what what you do over the
long term is very important so I'll just
show you that's that's a combine
harvester our resting the rice on the
left side and directly planting the the
wheat just after harvesting the rice so
it's just fantastic so you can see the
amount of residue you have and oddly a
PC door is working what you can see
there also that's added to the the
combine harvester it's a straw
management system which is fretting was
true more evenly but you don't have
piles of straw and that's your your your
cedar works better another paper
interesting paper was trying to show a
nice one the policy issues showing the
trade-off that you can have on on
different things in in a system so the
effect of and I think that was in 2008
Water Act was taken in fact to save
water
they just delay the planting dates for
the authorized planting dates for rice
and that of course at the major impact
on the way farmers had to manage their
residue they didn't have much time so
this paper is quite interesting because
showing in fact the difference that you
have in term of crop residue burning and
air pollution before the Water Act and
after the water
and of course and these one of the lead
author of that that publication so
health issues taken seriously in India
as well so I think it's if you look in
the news both national and international
news crop residue burning is is a
burning issue in in South Asian
especially in India and you could see
that the quick scaling of a p-series
in two states of India Northwest India
Punjab in and Arianna between 2010 to
2018 and of course there were subsidies
to manufacturers and to service from
providers to purchase the equipment so
it's not always you know without
subsidies wouldn't have been possible
because the EPI cedar is quite an
expensive piece of equipment equipment
and it's just used to three weeks a year
so that's so not right now what we are
doing we are monitoring and and they
still working on those topics were
monitoring in fact the evolution of
Prophecy burning in that in that region
so the way forward for us I think we
have increased a visibility of our work
I mean again visibly it is important if
you want to sustain and continue it
where funding for that type of work the
scaling work as well I think our role
has been a knowledge broker through
systemic approach we are not just
narrowly looking at engineering we want
to keep strong linkages between
mechanization and more sustainable
agricultural practices and it's it's a
natural match if you look at
conservation agricultural mechanization
say it's a natural match we want to
enhance general youth relevant technical
innovations and the scaling and that's
not only for field operation it's also
post harvest and transport we want to
explore new regions I think we have been
discussing with well in West Africa was
with Benin was the Minister of
Agriculture strong interest from one day
as well where the mechanization program
developed in that country Southeast Asia
we are not very present in Southeast
Asia we are almost absent in Southeast
Asia and we are looking at opportunities
to work there as well and we want to
develop also South as collaboration
China Africa India Africa and
public/private partnership approaches
India as fantastic engineers in in input
job and I think I can really surf Africa
so it could be win-win solutions options
in terms of business development in
terms of benefits for smaller farmers in
Africa
so then we want to keep our key
collaborations what further with a few
and the gi8 mechanisation platform so
right now in the CG where we're
reinventing ourselves and we are
wondering whether we should have an
initiative on mechanization or not it's
not yet proposed I think but it could be
something where I think all city centers
would be interested in working on a
systemic approach to to make -
mechanization
so thank you well I didn't money to at
the time I was not a little bit early to
ask you if you are a small boat without
a lot of resources how do you actually
access some of this mechanization what's
the actual or well there are places
where there's no access yet
I think it's developed developing
business models which would involve
probably financial financial schemes
would involve public and private sector
so in India is flying I mean it's it's
not that difficult in Bangladesh is a
lot of momentum around that as well in
Africa we have to prime the pump because
there's nothing and so our research in
the FATA C project was just to was more
discovery face on mechanization options
using two-wheel tractors and we see I
mean you have seen the figures in terms
of cost timing yields maze it's a
no-brainer when you see that but now the
challenge is to build an ecosystem
around mechanization and I think that's
what we I mean that's what we want to do
because new research questions will
emerge when you start having adoption of
those technologies another thing is and
I didn't present it a year but it's the
targeting you know what what are the
low-hanging fruits when it comes to
where to put mechanization where to
start it we need to initiate that
somewhere and it's not in the middle of
the bush for committee to city issues
from it's important having farmers were
more aware of you know more eager to
make a nice also
so as range of criteria on the way we
should we should start and we are
looking for you know performance support
as well in doing that so we are not
working alone we work with advanced
research institution but also with
national research organizations NGOs in
some cases in in Bangladesh we work with
quite a lot with idea so so there's no
not an easy option for for that but I
think it's it's really context specific
and now you want to how we can scale
that but we don't have impact at scale
in Africa yet but we want where it is
the model more performers themselves to
mechanize or is the model more for a
custom that is a sector that provides a
mechanization you shall do laser
leveling which obviously has to be on
the commercial sector but I'm also
thinking of planting and harvesting even
in the United States there's a lot of
custom custom plowing custom harvesting
though even with farmers with a lot of
possibility they could invest but
instead it's more efficient for a sector
to arise and so where is your your
emphasis there are those are both models
that you think would apply in different
countries we have for service provision
and in most cases those are farmers
becoming service providers I mean we saw
that in Europe as well yes no point in
buying a large combine harvester if you
have 50 acres of wheat I mean it doesn't
make sense and for most systems it's
like that as well so we are trying to
you know provide incentives or you know
and knowledge for investment in term of
service provision so you saw that youth
group they are really youth and they
just invested in the the thing they will
probably help in buying mesh error but
they paid it back very very quickly so
it's those type of things you know
positive variance in the way working
landscape will
incentive i order but you need a
critical mass I mean you cannot just if
one you know mechanize service provider
somewhere because that guy will not be
you know welding to get equipment will
not be welding to get repairs and things
that so it's a full system that we need
to develop and I believe that the you
know learning from from South Asia India
but also Bangladesh waveforms are much
more than even in Africa can be very
useful for for developing schemes for
poor for free thank you yes over here no
no no I I work for the livestock
Research Institute before I don't say
get rid of the livestock don't use
livestock for for powering your
operations in a farm because usually
those are you know in Ethiopia for
example pair of oxen they are not used
for milk production when at the end of
the life and maybe a bit of meat but
they are eating a lot fun non-productive
function except operations in the field
so if you look at the economics it's
better to invest in dairy cattle than in
cattle for for animal traction so that's
my point I don't say the get rid of the
yeah yeah well that's but you could
still have livestock but not to do your
traction you feed them to produce milk
which is a much more rewarding way of
looking at thing yes
we have projects in Mexico which is
North America we have worked in in
Guatemala quite a bit on milpa systems
on hills
so it's mechanization was not a top
priority there because those are complex
you know farming systems mill pallets
several species sloppy fields so erosion
problems but I think very few
opportunities for mechanization in goes
in those systems and further south we
don't have funding to work in the most
Latin American countries I think it's
you know the fundings also the thing
that's driving us where we work you know
what's our presence of maize or wheat in
systems and then the funding we can yes
oh yeah there was a question there for a
long time yeah sorry I actually read a
couple of adaptation or adoption
adoption of two-wheel tractors and and
you gave a couple of good examples of
this or where I'm going one is the corn
sheller and one is what other idea I
mean from this adoption perspective what
other ideas are you following up whether
directions that you're coming up with
that these two-wheel tractors can be
used for Co uses but are not directly
tillage type of you know those those
would be transports transport transport
is a big problem and if you look at
market distribution in Africa usually
people have to walk a lot to access
markets both for inputs but also for the
products they want to sell so you know
tool tractor we serve these are trailers
it's much better than using a donkey or
even using your your back to transport
things so transport is the thing we are
really looking at as well
so any question about the integration of
organization like how available is fuel
and when you're thinking about actually
thinking about the design and
inspiration for the context fuel let's
feel free I know what you have to build
those systems I mean again I mean in
India is not a problem in Bangladesh is
not a problem but if you're in the
middle of nowhere in landscape in Kenya
Tanzania or simbad way you have to
develop those those surfaces as well so
it's a it's a full ecosystem when you
look at and with the the data we we have
we believe that it's worth investing for
governments to invest in in
mechanization in the country so that's
and that would be you know not I would
say that would be national investment
for that so that's the type of you know
pledge or Clee we do when we we discuss
with national research programs and
governments on mechanization and that's
the the requesting one that came for the
Minister of Agriculture and she said we
won't submit to be involved in
mechanization and we want to be what in
our country a chip is very receptive the
only problem is that sometimes people
are just want to take shortcuts and take
the very simplistic approach the resume
mechanization to just buying equipment
if you buy equipment you'll go back to
the the World Bank investment in the 80s
where you just get the thing not use and
destroy in few months so unless you have
trained people you have workshops we
have retailers you have you have the
support in term of fuel and so on
there's no point in investing that's not
the first step the first step is not
buying the equipment that's the easiest
thing to do that's probably the thing
that will not work if it's done in
isolation of the to the rest are you
seeing any opportunities for
electrification so all local solar power
battery
yeah we can I mean we have not look at
that and in particular but I think there
are programs in in India for example
looking at you know the the energy
approaching in farming systems and of
course it's something very very
attractive yes that could be parts I
mean if you look at mechanization under
that umbrella you can put a lot of a lot
of things linked to energy use in in
rural systems as well so energy
production energy so it's this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu